these people that I refer to as the
subsection on the Left I refer to as the
regressive left have good intentions I
recognize that I also recognize that the
road to hell is paved with good
intentions and I think it's important to
understand that I am a Muslim I'm born
and raised a Muslim and every single
grievance that my fellow
well-intentioned liberals are worried
about that a Muslim may have I have
experienced they worry about racism I've
had neo-nazis come at me with hammers
and knives and machetes I've had to
watch friends stab before my eyes
friends had hammers put to their heads
I've you know I've seen all of this
growing up I've witnessed this and I've
experienced it they were worried about
the war on terror well I've been a
victim of the war on terror I've
witnessed torture in an Egyptian jail
I've been into interned without charge
and eventually I've been a prisoner of
conscience adopted by Amnesty
International they're worried about
profiling of airports at airports I've
had my DNA taken from me forcibly
without my consent I've had my right to
silence taken from me under British war
on terror laws everything they're
worried about I've had happen to me and
I say this therefore from a place up
that is concerned about these civil
liberties issues for Muslims because
I've suffered them myself and when I say
to these well-intentioned regressive
leftists is that your good intentions in
not having this conversation
not differentiating Islamism Islamist
extremism the ideology briefly
summarized as the desire to enforce a
version of Islam over Society your
intentions in not isolating Islamist
extremism from the religion of Islam are
making the problem worse not better it's
what I refer to as the Voldemort effect
you know we know in Harry Potter you
know there were people who the role of
what is a bad guy the evil character in
Harry Potter the ingenious device that
JK Rowling as an author came up with in
in those books was that the people were
so petrified of this evil character that
two things happened one they they
couldn't even name Voldemort they had to
refer to Vold and what is
he-who-must-not-be-named and then the
second thing was that he who must not be
named didn't even exist so they couldn't
name the thing they didn't even
recognize existed because that's how
scared they were now of course what
happened as a result is this denial of
the problem only increased the fear and
increased the hysteria around this
character Voldemort because he became a
legend a myth
and an all-powerful myth that everyone
was petrified of and that's what happens
when we refused to name Islamist
extremism we make the problem worse two
particular problems happen in refusing
to name Islamist extremism one is that
the right wing out there those who are
not the right wing but the faction again
within the right wing those who are the
anti-muslim bigots in not naming
Islamist extremism we leave the door
open for the anti-muslim and racist
crowd to hijack this debate and say yes
the problem is every single Muslim so
we're not providing a lexicon that that
were able to use to differentiate every
single Muslim from Islamist extremism
the second problem is an internal
problem within Muslim communities we're
depriving crucially those liberal
reforming voices from having the ability
to have those debates within their own
communities and say yes I'm a Muslim -
so don't monopolize my religion you're
an Islamist you're claiming to have the
correct version of my religion and you
want to enforce it over me I reject
Islamism and I'm not going to reject the
religion of Islam itself so they're able
to have that reformed discourse within
the communities and so I think that's
what's despite these good intentions
it's making the problem worse to deny it
the Voldemort effect is increasing the
hysteria it's one of the things I mean
very critical as a liberal about
President Obama's policy in that he has
succumbed to the Voldemort effect and
he's not he's up until now unable to
name the Islamist ideology